[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
selten haben sich mit drei herren in
einem holzgetäfelten zugabteil derart
hohe erwartungen verbunden der deutsche
bundeskanzler frankreichs präsident und
italiens ministerpräsident auf dem weg
nach kiel zu einem besuch mit ganz
vielen herausforderungen brenzlige
sicherheitslage beschwerliche anreise
das besondere flair der ukrainischen
staatsbahn aber natürlich vor allem die
appelle eines landes das dringend mehr
hilfe wünscht gerade aus deutschland
guten abend ihnen ein ich spreche gleich
mit bundeskanzler olaf scholz in kiew
über eine dienstreise die er wohl auch
selbst so schnell nicht vergessen wird
deutschland frankreich italien rumänien
sind für einen sofortigen
kandidatenstatus der ukraine für eine
aufnahme in die eu das ist ein
historischer tag sagt der italienische
regierungschef auch wenn es bereits
jetzt andere kandidaten länder gibt die
schon seit vielen jahren vergeblich
darauf warten dann auch wirklich eu
mitglied zu werden ein zeichen war es
allemal und eines auf das präsident
waldemar zielinski in kiew sowohl
gewartet als auch gesetzt hatte mein
kollege dara hassanzadeh ist in kiew
begrüßung in kriegszeiten pünktlich zur
ankunft und bundeskanzler scholz in kiew
ein luft erlernen
der krieg holt den noch vor seiner fahrt
nach ihn ein eine ortsbegehung die
scholz vor wochen noch für entbehrlich
wohnhäuser inzwischen mahnmale des
krieges eindrücke die nahe gehen die die
regierungschefs in den heutigen
verhandlungen mit selen ski mitnehmen
werden
umso schlimmer wenn man sieht wie
furchtbar sinnlos diese gewalt ist die
wir hier sehen sind unschuldige
zivilisten betroffen sind häuser
zerstört worden ist eine ganze stadt
zerstört worden in der überhaupt keine
militärischen infrastrukturen waren und
das sagt sehr viel aus über die
brutalität des russischen andreas fix
der einfach auf zerstörung und eroberung
aus ist und das müssen wir bei all dem
was wir entscheiden mit im blick haben
es war ein langer anlauf den der
bundeskanzler zu dieser reise genommen
hat es geht im nachtzug nach kiew scholz
makro und trage die europäischen
schwergewichte werden auf klare
ukrainische forderungen treffen mehr
waffen mehr sanktionen gegen russland
und der wunsch
eu-beitrittskandidat zu werden
das ist ein starkes zeichen der
europäischen einigkeit dann alle ukraine
wir wollen über die aktuelle situation
und die zukunft sprechen denn wir wissen
dass die kommenden wochen für uns alle
sehr schwierig werden
diesen händeschütteln ging ein
ausgelassener bundespräsident große
verbitterung und gegenseitige
missverständnisse voraus jetzt sitzen
sie zusammen mit am tisch der druck
ergebnisse zu erzielen auch als
botschaft an russland
meine damen und herren meine kollegen
und ich sind heute ihren aktiv gekommen
mit einer klaren botschaft
ukraine gehören zur europäischen familie
ein meilenstein auf ihrem voraussetzung
reichen europäischen weg ist der status
eines beitrittskandidaten
deutschland ist für eine positive
entscheidung zugunsten der ukraine
das gilt auch für die republik moldau
auch die anderen staatsgäste sichern der
ukraine ihre unterstützung auf ihrem weg
nach europa zu
wie kanzler scholz zuvor gesagt hat
hängt in der tat alles von der
zustimmung aller eu mitglieder ab aber
heute bin ich sehr glücklich dass die
regierungschefs dieser länder 100%
unsere kandidatur zum eu-beitritt
unterstützen das ist ein beeindruckendes
ergebnis ein historisches ergebnis für
unser land die historische bedeutung so
richtig spürbar war sie heute nicht in
kiew es war ein tag mit luftalarm aber
doch ein guter tag es gab keine
einschläge
aus dem stadtzentrum von care vor dem
weltberühmten sankt michaels kloster ist
der bundeskanzler jetzt bei uns guten
abend olaf scholz
guten abend hat sie was die ukraine
hatte appelliert herr scholz kommen sie
zu uns jetzt im krieg um das selbst zu
sehen jetzt sind sie da was war denn
heute ihre eindrücklichste erfahrung
die eindrücke des zip erfahrung waren
die zerstörungen die wir im team gesehen
haben das ist schon brutal dass der
russische angriffskrieg dort an schäden
hinterlassen hat und natürlich auch wie
viele menschen dort ihr leben verloren
haben das sind zerstörungen einem ort
der überhaupt keine militärische
infrastruktur hatte dass es nur gemacht
worden um der zerstörung will und das
zeigt mit welcher brutalität russland in
diesem krieg vorgeht sie haben immer
gesagt sie wollen kein zitat kurzes rein
raus mit fototermin machen das sah
präsident selensky ganz genauso jetzt
war es aber so dass seine wünsche und
ihr angebot die schienen bislang doch
erheblich auseinanderzuklaffen jetzt
kommen sie heute mit dem versprechen
sich für einen kandidatenstatus der
ukraine in der eu einzusetzen was
konkret bedeutet denn so ein status für
ein land im krieg
es wird deutet zunächst mal das hoffnung
auf den weg nach europa für die
bürgerinnen und bürger ganz konkret wird
und natürlich auch viel anstrengender
das ist ja kein einfacher soll ein sehr
voraussetzung voller weg der auch sehr
lange zeit in anspruch nehmen kann das
weiß er aber jeder und es geht darum
dass es sich lohnt die anstrengungen zu
unternehmen die gesellschaft zu
demokratisieren das was an rechtsfragen
zu lösen es zu lösen die fragen die sich
mit themen wie korruption und
irgendwelchen verbinden auch auf den
richtigen weg zu lösen und dafür zu
sorgen dass so etwas keine rolle spielt
in der gesellschaft und diese
anstrengungen die wir von jedem der
mitglied der europäischen union
verlangten werden will verlangen die
wollen hier auch alle auf sich nehmen
aber das klingt jetzt nach einem sehr
sehr langen weg bis es dann tatsächlich
zu einer mitgliedschaft kommen kann
korruptions problematik
rechtsstaats problematiken in der
ukraine haben sie einen zeithorizont
also wann wann ungefähr kann denn die
ukraine dann wirklich mitglied sein
in der europäischen union existiert
darüber konsens es handelt sich um die
dinge die die
mitgliedstaaten die künftigen selber
entscheiden in dem was sie voranbringen
mich schnell sie vorangehen insofern ist
das keine frage die irgendjemand seriös
beantworten kann aber es lohnt sich das
ist doch die botschaft denn überall wo
es um mitgliedschaften geht müssen ja
entscheidungen getroffen werden muss man
sich von seiner eigenen bürgerinnen und
bürger stellen um veränderungen
durchsetzen
und da ist die perspektive wichtig
deshalb habe ich bei dieser gelegenheit
hat ja auch gesagt dass es nicht nur um
die ukraine geht sondern auch andere
länder zum beispiel die länder des
westlichen balkans die schon das erste
mal im jahre 2003 ein beitritt
versprechen bekommen haben viele sind
schon sehr weit fortgeschritten und da
müssen jetzt ganz konkrete nächste
schritte erfolgen für die ich mich ja
auch seit langem einsätze und wo ich
auch vor kurzem erst viele lernen
habe das heißt also auch diese länder
müssen jetzt so schnell wie es geht in
die eu geholt werden weil sonst ja alle
auf so einem ewigen kandidatenstatus
fahren der am ende niemandem was bringt
verstehe ich das richtig
da müssen jetzt ganz konkrete
fortschritte passieren und wenn ich zum
beispiel zwei länder konkret benennen
darf nord mazedonien albanien haben all
die voraussetzungen erfüllt dass es nach
der langen zeit in der sich schon
kandidat sind jetzt darum geht die
beitritts konferenzen zu eröffnen und
dazu beizutragen dass jetzt über
verschiedene fragen verhandelt wird die
für die weitere entwicklung wichtig sind
das wäre ja herr bundeskanzler doch eine
sehr neue europäische union ein
einschnitt auch für die eu haben sie
denn für all das was sie da jetzt
vorgeschlagen haben auch den rückhalt
der anderen länder in der eu den sie
brauchen und zwar alle anderen länder
mario draghi und immer eine makro und
ich haben sehr genau darauf hingewiesen
dass wir einen konsens brauchen und
wollen es geht also schon darum dass
jetzt die verschiedenen perspektiven der
mitgliedsländer der europäischen union
zusammen geführt werden wir auf der
basis dann eine gemeinsame entscheidung
treffen dass die europäische union einig
und zusammenbleibt das ist auch wichtig
für den nächsten europäischen gipfel
der bundeskanzlerin bis gestern abend
selbst noch in der in der ukraine
unterwegs gewesen hat mit vielen
menschen dort geredet und wenn man mit
den menschen dort redet sagen alle einem
wir werden kämpfen egal wie lange es
dauert bis wir gewinnen in deutschland
fragen viele menschen nach einem ende
des krieges wann hört das endlich auf
wie wollen sie diese beiden pole
zusammenbringen
wir fragen auch alle wann hört das
endlich auf und das ist natürlich am
einfachsten wenn putin seine
verbrecherischen pläne beendet und sich
zurückzieht deshalb geht es immer darum
dass wir mit all dem was wir machen
unseren finanziellen hilfen den
humanitären hilfen aber auch den
waffenlieferungen und den sanktionen die
wir in großer einigkeit nicht nur in der
europäischen union auf den weg gebracht
haben dass wir mit all diesen
mitteln und wegen erreichen dass der
krieg ein ende findet klar ist das wird
keinen diktat frieden geben können nach
putins gnaden sondern es muss etwas sein
und die ukraine die bürgerinnen und
bürger das parlament der präsident auch
zustimmen können aber die menschen in
der ukrainischen ende einen ganz anderen
die idee davon zu haben wie man dahin
kommt der chefunterhändler des
präsidenten hat uns gesagt wenn man 20
mal weniger artillerie hat als russland
dann ist es unmöglich über ein
annehmbares ende des krieges zu sprechen
wird in deutschland der ukraine jetzt
helfen so etwas wie ein waffen
gleichgewicht mit russland herzustellen
sie sprechen genau das thema an um das
es geht artillerie da hat deutschland ja
schon vor einiger zeit die entscheidung
getroffen dass wir unsere ziemlich
modernen waffen die da zur verfügung
stehen auch liefern werden zusammen mit
den niederlanden in deutschland findet
gegenwärtig das training dazu stadt
übrigens eng abgestimmt mit der ukraine
weil das waffen sind die man nicht
einfach irgendwo hinstellen kann sondern
da muss erst mal drauf geübt werden das
passiert gerade und dann werden die
waffen auch geliefert im übrigen haben
wir in einem trilateralen programm
zusammen mit großbritannien und den usa
auch angekündigt dass wir
weitreichendere waffen auch zur
verfügung stellen das wird ganz konkret
bestehen mit unserem system mars und
anderen die die usa und großbritannien
haben die aber zusammen passen und das
gehört also zu unserer antwort auf diese
frage genau das ist jetzt erforderlich
genau das machen wir
herr bundeskanzler ist kann ihn in der
vergangenheit ja nicht gefallen haben
nämlich jetzt mal an dass präsident sie
den ski immer wieder deutschland
kritisiert sie auch ganz persönlich und
andere dagegen demonstrativ lobt hat er
ihnen heute gesagt er werde damit
aufhören in zukunft
ich tue das wozu ich an amtseid
geschworen habe als deutscher
bundeskanzler und das heißt in diesem
fall ganz konkret die ukraine dabei zu
unterstützen dass ihre integrität und
souveränität verteidigen kann dass die
ukraine ein demokratisches land sein
kann mit einer eigenen armee dass seine
eigene sicherheit gewährleisten kann und
das nicht von seinem nachbarn bedroht
wird und wurde nachbarn nicht versucht
einen teil des territoriums an sich zu
reißen das ist das was wir gemeinsam
voranbringen wollen und gleichzeitig
geht es natürlich immer auch darum zu
verhindern dass es eine eskalation des
krieges gibt er einen krieg so dass das
ein krieg zwischen nato und russland
wird und darüber sind wir uns alle einig
insofern war das heute wie übrigens bei
all den anderen gesprächen die ich
konkret und direkt mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten geführt habe in brüssel in
münchen in kiew schon vor langer zeit
und jetzt wieder hier in tief und bei
vielen gesprächen am telefon sehr
freundlich er sagte uns noch am montag
er habe den eindruck dass sie die
balance immer versuchen ein wenig
aufrechtzuerhalten zwischen russland auf
der einen seite der ukraine auf der
anderen seite und er eben nicht ihre
uneingeschränkte solidarität habe ist
das jetzt ausgeräumt
ich sage ganz klar die haltung
deutschlands zur ukraine ist sehr
offensichtlich ich habe kurz nach
kriegsausbruch eine rede im deutschen
bundestag gehalten ich habe von der
zeitenwende gesprochen die der russische
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine mit sich
bringt was jetzt macht das recht brechen
soll und dass das die friedensordnung in
europa gefährdet und ich habe
entschieden dass deutschland waffen
liefert und dass wir dafür sorgen dass
die bundeswehr ausreichend
ausgestattet wird und wir ein
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
auf den weg bringen alles sehr klare
fragen klare antworten wo man eigentlich
keine fragen mehr nach haben muss und
haben auch noch die glocken von st
michael gehört herr bundeskanzler in
kiew ganz herzlichen dank für das
gespräch heute abend
schönen abend und
das gespräch habe aus termingründen am
frühen abend aufgezeichnet deutlich
größer als die hindernisse bei der
anreise waren ja die im vorfeld des
besuchs das ging vom missverständnis bis
zur missstimmung und die frage wann
fahren sie nach kiew begann den
bundeskanzler irgendwann auf schritt und
tritt zu verfolgen mathis feldhoff jetzt
aus berlin über eine lange geschichte
davor und die reaktionen danach
zu sehen ist ein zufriedener kanzler
heute in kiew gemeinsam mit den kollegen
aus frankreich aus italien aus rumänien
schließlich versprechen sie der ukraine
die europäische perspektive eine
perspektive die auch in berlin gelebt
wird das ist ein sehr klares zeichen der
solidarität mit der ukraine und die
ansage dass
deutschlands begleiten und unterstützen
wird das ukraine und die moldau den
status eines beitrittskandidaten
bekommen und dann eu-mitglied werden
wenn sie die kriterien erfüllen ist
einfach nur eine gute nachrichten das
bedeutet dass sich schneller in die eu
kommen sie müssen regeln sie müssten
voraussetzungen erfüllen das kann lange
dauern es gibt also auch keine abkürzung
aber signal ist wichtig an die ukraine
aber auch an wladimir putin weil das was
er hoffte uns auseinander zu dividieren
das funktioniert nicht im gegenteil die
ukraine ist auf dem weg in den westen
doch stolz erfüllt auch manche
erwartungen nicht im gegensatz zu seinem
französischen kollegen makro nutzt den
besuch um weitere schwere haubitzen zu
avisieren in deutschland wird bekannt
dass statt der versprochenen vier
systeme maß zwei raketenwerfer nur drei
aus den beständen der bundeswehr
geliefert werden
deutschland bleibt unter der
bundeskanzler scholz erneut zurück und
das ist unterlassene hilfeleistung in
einer dramatischen internationalen
situation in einer kriegssituation in
der ukraine es geht darum dass das die
ampel und wahrscheinlich auch persönlich
der bundeskanzler grünes licht gibt für
diese lieferungen der industrie darum
geht es das dass der kanzler hier auch
vielleicht über den schaden entspringt
und sagt ja es kann nicht anders sein
doch das was deutschland zugesagt hat
etwa das flugabwehrsystem iris t lässt
bisher auf sich warten erst im oktober
könnte es soweit sein olaf scholz
verteidigt diese lieferungen für teile
der kritiker der völlig falsche ansatz
ich finde vernünftig dass man sich nicht
in einen wettlauf begibt höher schneller
weiter was die waffenlieferungen
betrifft die waffen werden keinen
frieden schaffen am ende des tages muss
eine diplomatische lösung stehen ein
lang erwarteter besuch und sehr
erwartbare reaktionen in berlin
heute gucken alle nach kiew ganz
vorneweg bei der eu klar für die sich
einiges ändern dürfte der bundeskanzler
hat dass hier gerade betonte in der
sendung nachdem vier eu staaten heute
gesagt haben wir wollen die ukraine auf
längere sicht dann in der eu haben und
natürlich schauen sie auch in moskau
genau hin obwohl der frühere russische
präsident medwedew heute noch gesagt
hatte das sei ein besuch zitat der
europäischen fans von fröschen
leberwurst und spaghetti bringen wir
unsere korrespondenten mit dazu zunächst
florian neumann in brüssel florian auf
dem eu-gipfel nächste woche soll dann
von allen gemeinsam über diesen
kandidatenstatus für die ukraine
entschieden werden gibt es denn dann
auch fragezeichen nach dem auftritt der
vier heute in kiew ja definitiv einige
fragezeichen und große hürden die erste
kommt gleich morgen dann wird die eu
kommission hier ihre einschätzung
vorlegen ob sie die ukraine für reif
genug hält das wird noch leicht
überspringen sein denn man wird die ich
höre ein jahr mit einigen bedingungen
formulieren aber dann kommt nächste
woche der eu-gipfel da müssen alle 27
mitgliedsstaaten der eu diesem
kandidatenstatus zu stimmen das wird
eine deutlich größere hürde es gibt noch
einige durchaus gewichtige skeptiker in
den reihen der eu portugal etwa
österreich einige nordeuropäer und wer
weiß sie sich ungarn am ende verhalten
wird ich denke aber am ende wird man
sich auf diesen kandidaten status mit
einigen bedingungen einigen können was
das ganze auch erleichtern dürfte ist
dass das ganze nur eine rein symbolische
frage ist ohne irgendeine folge
rechtlicher politischer oder
wirtschaftlicher art für die ukraine das
ist vielleicht ganz wichtig das soll
jetzt auch noch mal klarstellen es geht
eben nicht darum dass die ukraine quasi
nächste woche mitglied der europäischen
union würde aber natürlich ist
langfristig das ziel eine
vollmitgliedschaft zumindest das ziel
der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer ist denn
das realistisch da erstmal nicht auf
jeden fall da gibt es ganz große hürden
und es gibt auch keine abkürzungen für
die ukraine wir heute der bundeskanzler
in kiew noch einmal betont hat der ganze
prozess dürfte also noch sehr lange
dauern nur einen vergleich zur
einordnung
2005 da bekamen nord mazedonien in
diesem status die ukraine jetzt bekommen
soll als kandidat für den beitritt zur
eu haben jetzt 2022 17 jahre später die
eu hat noch nicht mal begonnen mit
mazedonien zu verhandeln über den
beitritt zur eu das ganze zeigt also ist
dauert hier sehr lange es könnte so sein
dass nicht einmal die enkel oder der
erst die enkel von williams gegen diesen
beitritt zur eu erleben dürfen
gehen wir weiter nach moskau zu axel
sturm axel ich habe von fröschen deba
wurst und spaghetti grad schon geredet
was kommt denn außer sport aus moskau an
reaktion
na ja es gehört wenn man so will zur
tradition dieses konfliktes dass man
staatsbesuche in kiew von hier aus nicht
sonderlich dezidiert nicht pointiert
kommentiert das hat vor allen dingen
damit zu tun dass man natürlich in der
innen wirkung dafür sorgen möchte dass
man die geschlossenheit des westens
nicht sonderlich propagieren möchte dass
man dafür keinen raum schaffen will zum
anderen aber ist man natürlich auch
vorsichtig dass man das alles beobachtet
das ist sehr sehr sicher und so gab es
auch den kreml sprecher dimitri peters
kopf der heute mittag zwei sätze
verloren hat zum thema bundeskanzler
besuch und französischer staatspräsident
und die anderen staats und
regierungschefs in kiew sagte er würde
hoffen dass die
vertreter des westens die dann nach kiew
reisen sich zusammen mit selen ski
darüber unterhalten dass es wenig sinn
mache die ukraine weiter mit waffen
vollzustopfen denn das würde zitat das
leid der menschen nur noch verlängern
und auch der russische außenminister
sergej lawrow sagte etwas am rande der
petersburger wirtschaftskonferenz die
gerade stattfindet er sagte eine eu
mitgliedschaft für die ukraine das sei
etwas bei dem die eu gegen ihre eigenen
regeln gegen ihre eigenen normen
verstoßen würde und sich nur noch
geopolitisch motivieren lassen also das
sind die beiden wesentlichen zitate des
tages zu diesem tag dann herzlichen dank
nach moskau und natürlich auch nach
brüssel und hier in mainz bleibst du
hunger noch beim thema ukraine ganz
genau christian denn in brüssel haben
heute die nato-verteidigungsminister
zusammen und eines der zentralen themen
war dabei die verstärkung der truppen an
der ostflanke des bündnisses nato
generalsekretär stoltenberg sagte die
allianz müsse seine präsenz fähigkeiten
und bereitschaft substanziell ausbauen
auch über einen vorschlag deutschlands
wurde diskutiert dem aufbau einer
multinationalen kampftruppen brigade in
litauen der nato gipfel ende juni soll
abschließend darüber entschieden werden
gestern erst hatte die us-notenbank fed
angekündigt die leitzinsen weiter
deutlich zu erhöhen heute folgt nun
großbritannien und überraschend auch die
schweiz wegen der starken inflation wird
kräftig an den zins schrauben gedreht
und das hat direkte konsequenzen valerie
haller wie fielen die reaktionen heute
aus an den finanzmärkten ganz deutlich
und das ist auch kein wunder wenn drei
notenbanken die zinsen erhöhen dann
spricht das eine ganz klare sprache die
sorge der notenbanken ist groß dass die
inflation einfach aus dem ruder läuft
kalt erwischt hat die börse die
zinserhöhung der schweizer die bisher
sehr zurückhaltend waren bei dem thema
an den börsen schrillen die alarmglocken
sorgen um die ohnehin fragile konjunktur
in europa der dax mit über 3 prozent
deutlich in schweizer briten amerikaner
erhöhen die zinsen und zwar kräftig
damit ziehen so ziemlich alle großen
zentralbanken an einem strang und dieser
umstand lässt die europäische
zentralbank die gerade mal die erste
zinserhöhung in aussicht gestellt hat
ziemlich zögerlich aussehen für
aufregung sorgt heute aber auch die
weitere drosselung der gaslieferungen
aus russland becher auswirkungen werden
da befürchtet in erster linie dass es
teurer wird das gas das nun zugekauft
werden muss das kostet einfach mehr denn
die preise sind kräftig gestiegen
die gasversorgung in deutschland ist
aber laut bundesnetzagentur stabil
gleichzeitig warnt sie wenn über wochen
nur 40 prozent gas durch nord stream 1
geliefert wird dann bekäme deutschland
schon ein problem wirtschaftsminister
habe groove bevölkerung und unternehmen
jedenfalls zum energiesparen auf es ist
jetzt der zeitpunkt das zu tun jede
kilowattstunde hilft in dieser situation
bundesnetzagentur-präsident müller
schlägt eine zeitweise geringere
mindesttemperatur in mietwohnungen vor
derzeit liegt die ja zwischen 20 und 22
grad der mieter punkt allerdings der
lehnt diesen vorschlag ab und setzt
stattdessen auf freiwilligkeit
danke valerie nach frankfurt
die bundesbeauftragte für die opfer der
sed-diktatur zucker hat ihren ersten
jahresbericht vorgestellt dabei forderte
sie von den behörden eine einfachere
anerkennung von gesundheitsschäden wie
mit der verfolgung zu ddr-zeiten
zusammenhängen die sed opferbeauftragte
übte zudem scharfe kritik an
westdeutschen konzernen die früher waren
aus ddr zwangsarbeit bezogen bis heute
habe sich keines der größeren
unternehmen zur unterstützung der opfer
bereit erklärt
der niedersächsische verfassungsschutz
hat die afg als verdachts objekt
eingestuft das erklärte der präsident
der landesbehörde witthaut begründet
wurde der schritt damit dass ehemalige
flügel angehörige mit ihrem gedankengut
in die parteistrukturen der ard
eingesickert sein zudem wurden
verbindungen zu rechtsextremistischen
organisationen und protagonisten genannt
der sommer hat noch gar nicht angefangen
doch schon jetzt hat eine hitzewelle den
südwesten europas fest im griff in
spanien sorgt das wetter bereits seit
wochen vielerorts für extreme
trockenheit eine folge sind zahlreiche
waldbrände so wie derzeit in katalonien
und auch in frankreich ungewöhnliche
hitze und das so früh im jahr wie noch
nie seit beginn der wetteraufzeichnungen
in zwölf die partners im südwesten des
landes wurde die warnstufe rot
ausgerufen
alle fünf jahre schauen kunstbegeisterte
aus aller welt nach kassel dann ist
documenta in nordhessen oft im vorfeld
schon von diskussionen und debatten
begleitet ist die documenta die
vielleicht wichtigste ausstellungsreihe
für zeitgenössische kunst weltweit ein
museum für genau 100 tage ein happening
von dem kassel aber auch bleibendes
abbekommt jetzt eröffnet die fünfzehnte
documenta und auf ihr wird vieles anders
sein als bei den 14 vorgängerin peter
theisen berichtet
wenn vor der altehrwürdigen orangerie
müll herumliegt dann ist wieder dokument
zeit in kassel die künstler vom nest
collective in nairobi haben elektro
schrott und altkleider ballen
mitgebracht return to sender heißt ihr
werk das uns einen spiegel vorhalten
will
man denkt ja dass diese altkleider alle
tragbar sind wenn sie den globalen
norden wie auch dieses land hier
verlassen aber es gibt statistiken dass
bis zu 40 prozent der kleider
unbrauchbar sind wenn sie in afrika
ankommen die landen dann also bei uns
auf der müllhalde
ein indonesisches künstlerkollektiv
kuratiert die weltgrößte schau für
gegenwartskunst alles steht unter dem
motto lumpen das indonesische wort für
eine reis scheune aus der die
überschüsse solidarisch geteilt werden
das ganze ist ein mechanismus ein
experiment wie wir unsere ressourcen
miteinander teilen können
gemeinwohl teilhabe und das brauchen wir
glaube ich in unserer gesellschaft sehr
dringend die künstlergruppe britto arzt
aus bangladesch möchte zeigen wie unsere
art des konsums in anderen teilen der
welt zu hunger führen kann
[Musik]
wenn man sich das ernährungssystem der
welt anschaut stellt man fest dass
einige wenige das ganze system
kontrollieren wir möchten dem neue
prozesse des lebens entgegen setzen
auf die kleinen dinge hinweisen die wir
schon
in ihrem garten bauen die künstler bio
gemüse an während der documenta sind
flüchtlinge hier zum essen eingeladen
und sollen auch ihre geschichten
erzählen
geschichten in bildern erzählt dann
pawlowski aus rumänien vor dem kasseler
hauptbahnhof zeichnet er kritische
kommentare auf den asphalt und kommt
darüber auch schnell mit passanten ins
gespräch
er erinnert sie an unser privileg der
freiheit
wir haben zum beispiel kober total
vergessen dort sitzen künstler im
gefängnis weil man seine meinung nicht
sagen darf genauso in der türkei was für
einen luxus haben wir hier dass wir uns
völlig frei ausdrücken können aber
künstler kollegen von mir sind im
gefängnis deshalb muss ich in ihrem
namen etwas sagen
die documenta sie soll bis september in
ständiger bewegung bleiben vor zwei
wochen startete ein künstlerkollektiv
aus berlin mit einem boot richtung
kassel angetrieben nur mit muskelkraft
wind und solarenergie
sie hoffen irgendwann ende juli auf der
documenta anzukommen
[Musik]
ein bild von unserer welt auf der
documenta auch bei maybrit illner geht
es gleich um das thema mit dem wir diese
sendung begonnen haben die reise nach
kiew warme worte oder echte hilfe
fragezeichen unter anderem dabei der
botschafter der ukraine in deutschland
und gegen 0.45 gibt's dann unser
heute-journal update mit nazan hatte mir
von uns allen ein angenehmes
[Musik]
guten abend in frankreich ist die hitze
bereits angekommen und am wochenende
erreicht sie uns auch hier in
deutschland zuvor muss aber noch so ein
kleines tief durchziehen das bringt vor
allen dingen schleierwolken mit und nur
ganz wenig regen dass die wolken dichter
werden da haben wir schon in dieser
nacht hier im nordwesten häufig aber ist
es klar und so sinken die temperaturen
zum beispiel im chiemgau oder am main
sowie am oberrhein auf 15 grad sieben
grad werden es zum beispiel in der
lüneburger heide und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zumeist zwischen 25
und 32 grad an der ostsee sind es 21 an
der nordsee aber wärmere 24 grad das
liegt daran dass dort der wind auf süd
dreht allerdings bringt dieses tief
etwas regen mit hier in nordfriesland
sonst ist es mal mehr mal weniger stark
bewölkt und am freundlichsten wird es am
oberheim so enorm ist die
waldbrandgefahr hoch aber die größte
waldbrand gefahrenstufe erwarten der am
samstag waldbrand gefahrenstufe 5 ist
erreichen in berlin-brandenburg teilen
von sachsen anhalt sachsen thüringen
bayern baden-württemberg und hessen von
aufenthalten in wäldern ist abzuraten am
samstag steigen die temperaturen bis 38
grad und dieser 38 grad werden dann am
sonntag von nordwesten von schauern und
gewittern abgelöst und wenn sie sich bei
solchen hohen temperaturen am wochenende
irgendwo abkühlen wollen dann sind
vielleicht diese temperaturen für sie
interessant diebinnen sehen in
deutschland haben meist werte um 20 grad
das wasser von nord und ostsee an den
deutschen küsten ist etwas kälter guten
abend